- Aw, the PJs! (laughs)
(upbeat jazz music)
- Favorite black characters?
Suzy from Rugrats was dope.
- Growing up, I was a '90s
baby, so I was a Rugrats kid.
Proud Family was great.
Kim Possible.
I used to stan for Kim Possible.
- Probably gonna mess up a lot,
so don't hold me to anything.
- Listen, that's where we gonna fuck up
'cause I don't remember
none of these theme songs.
- I wanna under sell and over deliver,
but, honestly, I feel
like I'm gonna kill it.
- That's the fat dude.
- It's over.
I don't know what the fuck that is.
- That's Fat Albert.
Yeah, I knew it.
I told you I knew that one.
- Fat Albert.
- That's Fat Albert, right?
- Was that Little Bill?
No, oh no!
I missed Fat Albert.
Okay, alright fuck it.
- Fat Albert.
Yeah, FUBU.
Platinum FUBU jerseys and all that shit.
Yeah, I know that one.
(upbeat jazz music)
- Is that Boondocks?
- I have no fucking' idea.
- Is this Static Shock?
- Listen, that was the one
person I was prepared for
was the PJs.
- Sing it, Solange.
- I don't know.
- I ain't gonna hold you.
Off rip I about to say,
♪ We're the Parkers ♪
but that's a whole
different fucking thing.
- The Proud Family
- That's Proud Family
- I think it was cool,
like, moving out to L. A.
and realizing, like, LaCienega Boulevardez
is just a fucking street.
- I don't know.
That one sounded like old-timey.
- Are we, like, in paper cut-outs?
I got nothing, again.
- That's Little Bill, right?
- The Harlem Globetrotters.
What?
Okay, well, that's not fair
'cause the part I remember
from the Little Bill theme song is
"Little Bill, Little Bill, Little Bill."
- I shoulda remembered that one
'cause my fucking brothers
used to drill me so bad
and call me Little Bill.
(sirens and drum beat)
- What the hell is that?
- I don't what that is,
but I feel the vibe.
- What was that one cartoon called?
It was like Static something.
- I can't even think of another name
to throw out there for you.
- This is my boy.
This was Fillmore,
out here slandering white
people with the dry chicken.
- I feel like I was grown
watching Law and Order.
when Fillmore came on.
(upbeat drumbeat)
- C-Bear and Jamal.
C- Oh my god!
- Sounds like Method Man or
Red Man or somebody rapping.
Static Shock.
- Kid and Play.
I now remember it.
I remember it now.
- Shit Wing It.
- I don't even know.
(party horn blows)
- I only missed one.
I feel like I got it.
- It was amazing to have these
characters to resonate with
and these cartoons to relate to,
but I don't know I think we
could still always do more.
- It was sad that the only
black animated girls that I saw on TV
came from The Proud Family.
- It's important not to get lost
'cause like me I was really out here
watching a lot of shows that
weren't black produced cartoons
and I'm lost right now.
- I think it's important
to have, you know,
yourself represented in cartoon form.
Those are the cartoons
that stuck out to me
I'm getting giddy
hearing these theme songs
that I haven't heard in so long.
(upbeat jazz beat)